pS links in the sidebar everybody's got
a question
as a bunch of you guys know it was back
in Pittsburgh last week and I was pretty
busy growing virtual trees and hanging
out with mariachi bands if you want to
know what I'm talking about
there's some links in the sidebar
whichever way that is hey g'day and
welcome to ask i J episode and number
nine yeah that's right nine that's
almost ten which brings me to the viewer
question what should I do for my 10th
episode hey Twitter question
alright J LOX has been repeatedly
spamming me on Twitter to answer his
question of if I had any superpower what
would it be and why well that's easy
it'd be fire so I could cook grilled
cheeses on the go it's totally normal
right oh and one more Twitter question
Mason asked me to go to prom for the
youtube comment question I'm just going
to address all of your comments
collectively but if you make a ketchup
milkshake while I can't honestly say
I've ever made or tried to make a catch
of milkshake I got two videos of some
people that actually succeeded in making
kitchen milkshakes let's check those out
get your milkshake consisting of ice
cream
and Heinz ketchup that's great Justin
thanks for the idea
ketchup milkshake just for you
yay time for video response questions
these are probably my favorite and I
honestly spend way too much time
watching all of your videos and don't
forget if I haven't answered one of your
video response questions feel free to
just repost it on my newest ask IJ video
enough of the blah blah blah let's get
to the video response question hey
Justine
I was just wondering what's your name I
don't have one
yeah I know it's pretty crazy does
anybody else not have a middle name or
is it just me that's it for ask IJ
episode number nine I'll see you guys
next week but don't forget to leave your
questions below add your video responses
and ask your questions on Twitter PS
don't forget to subscribe